hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play illusion ghost
killer okay now there's been a couple
other games called illusion but this is
illusion ghost killer I think I think it
has more to do with like the original
illusion that I played which had to do
with Jeff the killer so let's jump right
in obviously it's made from a different
country F for the Lanterna shift for AA
close down hoga door okay how do I go
back back okay good here we go este
lugar Ripley replace your decoy sauce I
don't know what this means I can't speak
this language I don't even know what
language that is position six cameras
ah-ah-ah in the area I'm I don't know
how no that was my objective okay so
obviously I am hindered oh hello look at
the rotating this wait was this am I
supposed to put a camera here huh so I'm
supposed to well it doesn't help when
it's facing the wall but okay I'm
supposed to put cameras around this
place to observe something what am i
observing what am i running away from
what am I trying to hide ah just chop
[ __ ] yeah nothing oh look at that I'm
stuck behind this box okay
hello ah what da [ __ ] do I get away get
away get away get that ah fetch what who
what I did uh wait a minute oh hang on a
second there what the hell is that
supposed to be well I know is Jeff the
killer but I mean come on he didn't even
give me a chance
um ah I just saw the picture of him and
then all of a sudden I heard ever
I was turn around and I didn't even know
that he was attacking b2b it okay
alright try this again obviously there
are some risks at work here
maybe you got upset because I I didn't
position this facing outward
ergo how was I ever gonna [ __ ] that
doesn't help
whatever I'll go not that way towards
the picture how was I even supposed to
know that he was creeping up on me
he like cornered me too I couldn't get
away from him okay whatever let's just
carry on don't see a red spot I don't
see a Jeff the killer
oh hi guy hi ru bye see you what up
freakin hell stop laughing at me oh
you're going gonna be laughing what I've
seen why are you outside
what uh-huh
well that's hardly fair if he's just
gonna pop up behind you that's not even
close to fair why did ah ah ah I want to
go back to Michigan this is not I enjoy
this give me a chance at least mr. Jeff
I mean mister the killer
okay so let's hurry oh no my kid first
camera spot isn't there this is a room
full of blood what if there's a red spot
hiding here how I know oh yeah I won't
oh wait this is familiar no thank you I
don't want any I see a red circuit can't
see you go by me if I don't have a back
you can't sneak up behind me
okay our hey way so you should start
peering up hearing I see another one
let's make a strafing run okay I got
three yeah doing good baby
where is he ah I don't know
what's that him I'm not sure it might
have guy the duck come on Boober I go
now don't laughing at me
I got funny face but you started your
funny face your face is the leak sure
perfectly rounded that's ah [ __ ] stop it
I mama dad I'm dead how the hell how I
both to get away long enough to play the
fruit of my eyes okay alright so when he
pops up I think I just need to keep
running and not stop for those red
things because once he starts chasing me
that means he's gonna keep chasing me
till I did until I dead and when I dead
amen as there's a good for my throat I
just got Chuck a break for three days of
not screaming you need to scream every
single day to keep your vocal cords nice
and crashed
nice give my speech impediment
okay now the heart beat starts which
means set Jeff the killer can't be far
behind
no I'm not going in there that's a trap
that's a god ball the rock chop a hole
ha
once I get my bearings I'm gonna zoom oh
my god come on stop it you dick you're
dead in a hole
ha ha oh it's so funny I'm bleeding out
why do I even need to put the cameras
here you think that I'd be like well I'm
investigating paranormal activity
oh yeah you're a psychotic killer Paul I
love you put my other cameras down us
stupid I shut up dog dog barking in this
job I'm trying to a card game shop dogs
that's the annoying one what do you guys
made a deny annoying one go away you
dick I don't even see where the red ones
that I've ever been here hi
[ __ ] you gone dead fine look go look go
to slip what does that mean and does the
same me you're dead voce Moreau why is
this in English man hi this game I don't
like this game I'm gonna give it one
last try and if I can't beat it
I then maybe there's some secret that
I'm not doing it right maybe I've like
need to turn off my flashlight when he's
chasing me or something or I don't know
or maybe I'm just screwed beyond all
belief that probably it I would believe
that would more than any other my ideas
I don't have many good ideas okay I get
it yeah okay let's go poke it yeah
hmm I don't think there's a red spot in
here but if there was I'm going to miss
it
how soon is he gonna pop out this time
let's see what's behind door number
three
eh oh you win a red circle on the ground
give me
oh come on what up hey [ __ ]
oh you red circles crossed me why time
oh shut up
kuru suddenly very dark ah [ __ ] house
stop it you [ __ ] how do I kill you how
do I kill the killer who kills a killer
where's Dexter when you need him Arie
I'm bub so up books [ __ ] you man this is
dancing your blue jig there I this
game's impossible I don't care you guys
are probably gonna be in the comments
like oh oh you so dumb you should have
just jumped a triple somersault into the
F button and then y'all man you still
stupid marklar what wrong with you and
then I'll be like sure cuz I scream a
lot mmm okay okay alright I'm all done
here so ah I don't know how to beat it
if you guys know how to beat it let me
know or unless this is just obscenely
impossible so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos if I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
I am
ah
Oh
Wow
you